موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم اعلنا حاكم مقاطعه
كورسكا الروسيه المحاديه لاوكرانيا عن
استهداف في مسيره اوكرانيه لمطار مدينه
كورس ما تسبب في اشعال النيران في خزان
وقود دون وقوع خسائر بشريه
اعتذارك بعد ساعات من استهداف في مطرين
عسكريين في وسط وجنوب روسيا بطائرات مسيره
اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه عسكريين روس واصابه
اربعه اخرين بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسي
قال الجيش الاوكراني ان مناطق كيف وخيرسون
وزباروجيا وميكو لايف تعرضت لقصف الروسي
بوابل من الصواريخ من البحر الاسود وبحر
قزوين ما تسبب في انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
على نطاق واسع
وقع عدد من القوى المدنيه ومجلس السياده
السوداني اتفاق السياسيا يؤسس لمرحله
انتقاليه مدتها 24 شهرا وتعهد رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان بمعالجه اخطاء
النظام السابق بشان المؤسسه العسكريه وقال
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الاتفاق مفتوح
لكل القوى الثوريه
بدوره وصف نائب رئيس مجلس سياده محمد
حمدان حميدي قرار الاستيلاء على السلطه
بالخطا السياسي واكد اهميه الاتفاق
الايطاري للانتقال بالسودان نحو
الديمقراطيه
من جهته قال ممثل القوى المدنيه المشاركه
في التوقيع الواثق البرير ان الاتفاق يهدف
الى توحيد السودانيين تحت رايته مشروع
اقامه سلطه مدنيه استكمال الانتقال
الديمقراطي وتحقيق اهداف الثوره
وغايته في تونس اكد المتحدث باسم حركه
النهضه عماد الخميري ان ما سماها سلطه
الانقلاب فشلت في اداره جميع الملفات
الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه وضالف الخميري ان الانتخابات
التشريعيه المرتقبه الشهر الجاري ستعمق
الازمه الدستوريه في البلاد
افاد مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان نقل نعم
مسؤول الحكوميه بمقتل ثمانيه اشخاص واصابه
19 في تفجير بعبوه ناسفه السهدف حافله
ركابا وسط مدينه مزار شريف شماليا البلاد
قالت وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه ان
وحدات من الجيش تلقت اوامر باطلاق المزيد
من القذائف المدفعيه باتجاه البحر ردا على
التدريبات العسكريه التي تجريها كوريا
الجنوبيه ياتي ذلك غداك اطلاق بيونديانج
اكثر من مئه وثلاثين قذيفه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء